ahead of its release stranger of
paradise final fantasy origin drew a lot
of jokes on the internet because of its
angry protagonist jack spending all his
time in the game's pre-release trailers
talking about how desperately he wanted
to kill chaos he just would not shut up
about chaos and it was funny because we
had no context for what that even meant
but playing the full game provides
little in the way of extra information
to explain jack's chaos rage at least
not until well into the game's 25
hour-ish run time in fact for the first
few hours jack is literally walking up
to every boss monster at the end of
every level to ask are you chaos
the confusion around jack and chaos is a
microcosm of the strange and sometimes
bewildering take on final fantasy that
is stranger of paradise this game is
part remake part reimagining and part
new chapter for the original final
fantasy from way back in 1987 but it's a
version of final fantasy with a lot of
final fantasy strained out what's left
is a streamlined version of the
venerated rpg series that is often a
blast to play thanks to its excellent
and varied combat mechanics and is also
perplexing as hell on nearly every level
stranger of paradise takes the usual
final fantasy formula of battling
monsters gathering gear exploring a vast
world and uncovering a lengthy story and
strips away almost everything that isn't
related to combat this is final fantasy
as a loot game where your strength is
dictated by the quality and rarity of
your weapons and armor every time you
enter a mission you get a rundown of the
rewards you'll receive by completing it
along with their numerical strength
levels just about every enemy you face
is a pinata filled with new boots and
swords and hats this is a game where you
grind for gear rather than experience
points as in a traditional rpg stranger
of paradise mixes a brand of the
fast-paced action rpg battle system of
the series other recent not quite remake
final fantasy vii remake with
hard-hitting enemies and a focus on
parrying enemy attacks it's a cliche to
compare everything to dark souls but the
inspiration of the souls-like approach
is clearly at play in stranger of
paradise and that elevates the combat
you have to take every enemy seriously
lest a small group of simple bats beat
the living hell out of you as happened
to me again and again and again
throughout the game you need to learn
how to read attacks so you can guard
parry or dodge them as the situation
dictates and everything from a looming
behemoth to a lowly goblin is a major
threat while it's worth noting that
there's a more chill story mode that
makes combat significantly easier the
strength of enemies on the normal and
hard difficulties helps make fighting
fun that's because you have a lot of
tools at your disposal and you'll have
to use all of them and that goes double
for its often massive intense boss
fights stranger of paradise's main
mechanic is the soul shield an ability
that you can use to absorb most incoming
attacks but with a short timer attached
that leaves you vulnerable if it runs
out when an enemy attacks activating
your soul shield parries them away while
giving you magic points you'll use mp
for everything from casting magic spells
to executing powerful melee combos that
means you need to be aggressive getting
into the thick of fights baiting out
attacks and parrying them to power your
own abilities successful parries help
lower your enemy's brake meter which
runs parallel to the meter dictating
their health empty the brake meter on
your foes and they'll be stunned opening
them up to a brutal finisher in which
jack magically crystallizes the foe from
the inside out and then shatters them in
a big explosion finishers eliminate
enemies with a flourish damage any other
foes close by when you use it and
increase your total mp gauge during the
current mission soul shield can also
sometimes absorb enemy attacks storing
them for a bit to use yourself when a
wind elemental casts an arrow spell at
you your soul shield can catch it
protecting you from damage and allowing
you to throw it back at your foes
that alone would be a really cool
incentive to learn attacks and practice
the timing to parry them but with the
brake gauge and the finishers you have
an excess of reasons to get good at the
game's parry system and it's always
rewarding to do so the drawback of the
soul shield is that if you mistime a
parry and an attack hits you jack will
be staggered and very vulnerable for a
couple of seconds to counter that
limitation you have a normal guard that
cuts down on damage received so fights
often start with you guarding to learn
an enemy's capabilities then breaking
out the soul shield once you get more
comfortable so you can let loose with
your best moves there are a whole lot of
those moves to keep track of though at
times stranger paradise benefits from
all that variety at others it can be way
too dense the game functions on a
variation of final fantasy's job system
in which you choose a certain job for
jack that comes with a specific approach
to combat allows him to equip specific
types of armor and weapons and unlocks
specific moves the fun part about all
this is that there are a bunch of jobs
giving you a variety of combat options
to explore each with their own central
gimmicks and weapons leveling up one job
almost always lets you unlock a new one
including advanced and expert level jobs
that are more specialized you can also
equip two jobs at a time each with its
own set of armor and weapons and quick
swap between them so if the situation
dictates that you need overwhelming
force you can use jack's swordsman job
to slice through the opposition if
you're fighting elemental enemies a
quick swap to the mage job lets you
blast enemies with water or fire spells
and take advantage of their weaknesses
you can also use some gear's job
affinity stat to gain bonuses from a job
even if it's not currently equipped
apart from managing jack's job and gear
you can also select from a few jobs for
your party members but the customization
is much more limited you also can't
control any of your allies directly in a
fight apart from using a special ability
that makes them a little fiercer every
so often
[Music]
all the customization lets you tune jack
to fight in a lot of different ways if
it sounds like a deluge of junk to keep
track of though it is and that's where
stranger of paradise can falter there
are so many combos affinities jobs
stances and command abilities that you
can easily lose track of them and once
you find a comfortable job and a few
effective combos you probably won't want
to mess with a good thing it can also be
punishing to switch jobs as you move
through missions because unleveled jobs
make you weaker than leveled ones so if
you're facing a tough mission for which
you're under-leveled the game pushes
against experimentation there's also
so much gear that you'll find yourself
constantly swimming in menus each
character uses specific weapons and
armor and all the weapons and armor have
different upshots and downsides along
with the rarity levels and job
affinities and some even unlock special
combos about halfway through my run i
just started hitting the optimize button
on the gear menu whenever i picked up
some significant piece of equipment
which felt like roughly every five to
ten steps there's also a crafting system
for upgrading your gear but the flood of
new equipment is so fast and furious
that it never really made sense to amp
up my equipment if i was just going to
replace it in the next mission or even
in the next fight the game's majority
focus on combat means stranger of
paradise mostly foregoes traditional rpg
aspects like visiting merchants
exploring towns or getting to know minor
characters but that streamlining hides
the fact that stranger of paradise is
still a very story focused game even if
its approach to story is kind of bizarre
jack and his friends overwhelming desire
to defeat chaos is confusing but that's
part of the point as you discover early
on that none of the protagonists the
prophesied warriors of light can
remember their pasts they have this need
to kill chaos and that's all they know
the story builds on this theme of memory
and mystery although the characters are
fairly flat and uninteresting and the
game never goes out of its way to really
develop them the story itself can be
pretty disjointed
cutscenes pop up during and between
missions but important concepts go
unexplained and barely remarked upon
even the idea that the warriors of light
are missing their memories is something
you'll first have to pick up from
context clues it's not until late in
stranger of paradise that it becomes
clear this is a recontextualization of
the original final fantasy and kind of
all the other games in the series as
well similar to the way hideo kojima
retconned the events of the nes metal
gear games through the course of metal
gear solid 4 and 5. until it all starts
to click it's just a mess of strangeness
derived from cut scenes and loading
screen text and it may never click at
all there are a few other choices in
storytelling that are baffling
inclusions
occasionally you'll be left in a room
where you can run around and talk to
some other characters including your
party members and a traditional rpg way
the segments are super brief with every
character only having one or two lines
the chats can be somewhat useful to the
story like when your teammate neon
recalls hearing about garland a
character fans will know as the primary
villain of the original final fantasy
the vast majority of the time however
it's just people saying useless things
like wishing you good luck in one spot
where i could talk to my party before
speaking with astos the guy who would
tell us where to go next neon's whole
optional dialogue line was jack you
should find out what astos has to say
why even create this option if it's only
to tell me to do the thing i was already
going to do
the game has a bunch of these optional
dialogue moments mostly separated to a
special between missions talk menu that
lets you check in with a small group of
townspeople to see how the world is
changing as you progress stranger
paradise purposely removes things that
dilute its focus on combat so you'd
think that any optional dialogue it does
include would be important to the story
the fact that so many of these scenes
are incredibly unimportant makes no
sense and only serves to slow the game's
pacing it should also be noted that
stranger paradise stumbles a bit on
technical aspects and at times its art
direction every level is a long trip
through a specific location and while
those locations are neat and varied from
mission to mission every one of them
quickly becomes a confusing labyrinth of
shortcuts and side paths the rooms
within each level are so samey that i
was constantly getting lost the game
looks good in motion especially as
you're knocking out finishers and firing
off elemental attacks it's at its best
when it's popping and overflowing with
color but some scenes and sky boxes are
a bit soupy and the characters are never
particularly well animated scenes with
small crowds of only 8 or 10 townspeople
include several of the same face running
the game on the playstation 5 in its fps
favoring performance mode i still saw a
fair share of frame rate stuttering as
well they were mostly minor annoyances
but in general this feels like a last
gen game a lot of the time with the
visuals and performance that go with it
still while it might be confusing and
memey and disjointed and weird stranger
of paradise is also a lot of fun it's
full of cool combat with a wide variety
of options and a job system that lets
you customize your playstyle or just try
out what feels like 30 different ones
its challenge makes every fight a battle
of skill while also giving you the tools
to feel like a ridiculously powerful
final fantasy badass and despite being
bizarrely delivered and wildly strange
there is a delight in uncovering what
the hell is actually going on in the
game's story and the weird ideas it
brings to bear on the final fantasy
series stranger of paradise is mostly a
more focused version of final fantasy
that shows some different directions for
the series from its traditional games
even if those directions take it down
some paths that are sometimes a bit
stranger
what
need something for that
it's just a scratch
nothing a little spit can't heal